-Our first guests tonight
starred in one of the most
iconic movies of all-time,
"Ghostbusters."
Now they're back in
"Ghostbusters: Afterlife,"
which is in theaters
November 19th.
Let's take a look.
-Guys.
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
-Aah!
-[ Gasps ]
It has a gunner's seat?
[ Grunting ]
♪♪
[ Cap creaks ]
[ Ghost screams ]
-Go, go, go!
[ Engine revving ]
-Please welcome to the show --
I hope I'm saying
their names right --
Bill Murray, Dan Aykroyd
and Ernie Hudson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome, gentlemen!
Uh, you know,
I was watching the film,
I was telling
you guys backstage.
It was very emotional for me
to watch the film.
I can only imagine
how emotional it was
for you guys to get back
together again.
-Just like --
It felt like yesterday.
It felt like we never
left the packs off
and never got out of
the jumpsuits.
Didn't it feel like it was --
we were military
called back to service.
It felt like that.
You know, we were called
from the reserves.
-Right, exactly.
[ Light laughter ]
-It was painful.
It was painful is what it was.
[ Laughter ]
It was physically
and emotionally painful.
You forget how heavy it is
to carry a small refrigerator
on your back
for hours and hours a day.
And then they say, "Okay, guys,
get down on the ground."
-Yeah.
-"Cut!
All right, stand up."
-No.
-"And then,
get down on the ground again."
That's what we did.
And I went,
"[Bleep] we did this
20 years ago."
-Yeah.
-We did a long time ago.
It's basically you're
falling down on the ground
and having to get up with a
small refrigerator on your back.
[ Laughter ]
-It seems like the magic
of moviemaking is,
they could've made
a lighter refrigerator
for your back.
-They had rubber ones,
but they don't --
when they're on,
it doesn't look like
you're carrying the weight
with the rubber ones.
-Yeah.
-So, we always --
because we're actors,
we're committed.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, put the heavy one on.
It'll look more real.
Sure.
-A little better
than the first -- the first --
-Yeah, the first one
weighed about
40-something pounds
or something.
We used to have it wear it for
like 14 hours a day.
-Yeah.
-So, it sounds crazy,
but, like, if you're a mother
and you have a baby,
and you carry your baby,
you know how that feels
after a few months.
Imagine that your child's born
at 40 pounds.
[ Laughter ]
-I still don't think
you're gonna get
a lot of sympathy from mothers
on that, Bill, but --
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-They're like,
"I thought I had it bad
till I heard about
the Ghostbusters."
[ Laughter ]
So this was sort of
the first big-budget film
that you had ever done, Ernie.
Did you have any sense
of what you were getting into?
-No. Well, I did "Spacehunter"
with Peter Strauss,
Molly Ringwald,
that Ivan Reitman produced.
-Never heard of it. Never.
-Neither has anybody else.
[ Laughter ]
But -- But the year before --
So but this was --
Yeah, this was pretty amazing.
Pretty incredible, yeah.
-You know, I was thinking back.
Like, when I think about
growing up in the suburbs
and wanting to live
in New York City, it's never,
like, the way Woody Allen
made it look beautiful.
It was jokes by David Letterman
about how garbage a city it was
and then "Ghostbusters," where
it was a city full of ghosts.
[ Laughter ]
And yet when I watched it,
I was like,
"That's where I wanted to live."
I mean, obviously, New York
was a huge part of this film,
of the first one.
Was it exciting for you guys --
I guess you'd been gone
from "SNL" about five years,
to come back to the city
and make it.
-Oh, sure. Well, any time
in New York City is exciting.
Uh, I love --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Love New Yorkers.
Love the architecture.
Not sure
that I would ever really
live here again full-time.
[ Laughter ]
But we had a great time.
It was wonderful because
we would be shooting
in civilian clothes,
and nobody would be
really looking,
and then we'd get on the packs
and the uniforms,
running down the street,
and people would kind of go,
"Are they exterminators?
Are they -- Well..."
[ Laughter ]
And then the Cadillac,
we'd be going all over town
in the Cadillac.
And there was hardly --
"That's just another
emergency vehicle, I guess."
You know, New Yorkers
were so blasé about it.
They weren't really impressed
at all with us at the time.
-It was a grand time
to be in New York.
We lived in New York
for a long, long time.
And to be able to be
a true New Yorker and to drive
and just completely
ignore stoplights
everywhere you went.
[ Laughter ]
And in that vehicle, nobody --
We all looked so legit
in the damn thing, you know?
And we had the refrigerator
on our back,
so people would just let you go.
Police would kind of go,
you know, "What the hell?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But I was surprised, 'cause,
you know, I think the movie,
you watch it now, and you assume
that you were fully permitted
and you had a key to the city.
But you were kind of
fly-by-night.
-Stealing things.
-We had the key to the city,
but they didn't know.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Right, they did not give you --
you took the key to the city.
-It was auxiliary kind of thing,
volunteer kind of stuff.
You know?
-You shot in 30 Rock.
And, you know, obviously,
you guys had worked here,
Dan and Bill.
But did you have --
-We did not have a permit for
the stuff we shot around here.
-Really?
-Yeah, we just jumped out,
and we were like,
"Hi! It's Dan and Bill.
We're shooting.
You know, nobody's gonna --"
You know, just kept going.
-Yeah, you can see the scenes
on Fifth Avenue when
we're figuring out the mortgage
and how to buy the equipment
and all that.
And we're just walking there.
And people -- it's real people.
We're walking there,
and they were totally oblivious
to the fact it was a film unit.
So what you're seeing
is real people
just on the street in New York.
And we were stealing everything
all over the place.
[ Laughter ]
Yep.
-Much like in the film,
you were sort of the last
Ghostbuster to join the team,
and you were coming into
a situation where the other guys
knew each other.
Did you feel welcome
when you came on the set, Ernie?
-Yeah, I felt like the neighbor
who goes to a friend's house,
and they're grabbing
all the food,
and you're trying to be polite
at the table.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I'm saying?
So, yeah, I was welcome,
but obviously, you know,
I got through it.
Harold would always say,
"Ernie, it's okay."
[ Laughter ]
-You reference Harold Ramis,
who sadly passed away.
He was the other Ghostbuster.
I imagine it's impossible
to go back to a film like this,
that you wrote with him,
Dan, and not think of him.
-Harold was a huge part,
of course,
of the first "Ghostbusters"
and the second one,
because of his -- just his
incredible intelligence,
his great sense of humor,
his frame of reference.
He -- You know, he was
a terrific co-writer,
and really a lead writer,
and once I handed him
that big, thick script,
he just knew,
"Yeah, we can do
this, this, and this,
make this work this way."
We sat down with Ivan,
wrote it in the basement
in Martha's Vineyard
for about three months --
or, a month it was, actually.
Three weeks.
-That's enough.
He's passed away.
[ Laughter ]
-And, yeah, he's the man, yeah.
-It is a little overkill
at this point, yeah.
-But he's still with us,
as you'll see.
-You could have said that
a long time ago.
He would've liked that.
-I did!
-He would've loved that.
He'd have loved
to have heard that.
-Bill, did you know
they were working
on a "Ghostbusters" film
and had plans for you
to be in it?
Is that something where like,
"Hey, you know, Harold and I
are writing a film called
'Ghostbusters'"?
-Well, I think I knew
before Harold knew,
because Danny sent me something.
And I think --
There's an allegation
that John Belushi
was gonna be invited, but --
Another guy whose passed away,
and we don't owe him anything.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But the original script
had about 27 --
The original thing Danny sent me
had about 27 pages in it.
And it was the funniest thing
I'd ever read in my life,
and I said, "Let's go."
And then the stories
get better from there.
[ Laughter ]
-I have more
to ask these legends.
We'll be right back after this.
[ Cheers and applause ]